what is happening there reject nation
aaron alexander is back with me
we are going to do a movie reaction
first time watching the film kung fu
hustle here's the truth i think i saw
this once when i was like 15 but if you
were to ask me
what happens in this movie what is the
plot anything i could honestly not tell
you anything
i don't know jack about it oh it's going
to be one of those experiences like even
recently i was re-watching the first
season of stranger things and i was like
i don't remember
so you can imagine how i don't remember
just more than 15 years i'm like i
really don't remember what happens it's
gonna be fresh look all i was trying to
do is remain truthful for you guys
however
i think i only thought i saw it because
after doing this reaction
i really think this might have actually
been my first time watching this he's
never seen this movie ever this was
recommended to us a bunch and i was like
this sounds like a fun movie so yeah if
you guys can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated full like watch alongs
we stick up with the time code for kung
fu hustle will be over on our patreon
page we cover a whole bunch of other
stuff over there as well subscribe click
that notification while we get notified
when we put up another movie reaction
for something else out there in the
meantime let's enjoy and thanks for the
proper boys for helping us edit these
down let's do it
[Music]
crime busters
wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
damn
[Music]
the axe gang right on axe gang
[Music]
okay okay leg day
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
oh wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
bro you got to pick it up a little bit
man just
just like four inches you could take a
lesson from him i could bro i'm taking a
class
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
terrible hustlers
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's fantastic
[Laughter]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
[Applause]
was an
elephant oh no the real axe gang is here
oh dang
it
oh snap
[Laughter]
what in the water brothers
oh
dang
what are these people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
the axe call
there's such like a sincere whimsy to
this movie it's very creative
oh god oh that's messed up
[Music]
jesus guys is this maybe gonna stop
being funny
[Music]
i just hope they don't dance after this
[Music]
someone's got to save him
hello new character
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh dang we're all just so
it's
talented
most badass village i've ever seen
oh
yes
yes
[Music]
he's got the rings baby
oh
[Applause]
great wire works
nice
dang was that his ult
these professional martial artists just
wanted to live in peace
[Music]
i've always thought about it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
sure the ma that's the director of this
movie there's stephen chow oh really
damn y'all gross
damn they could all pee on the same time
y'all got a lot of them impressive
bullets right all pizzas are done
creative
coordinated
[Music]
[Laughter]
one of those look half eaten already
[Music]
is that the girl he
protected i think i think so
they keep calling her fat she doesn't
because
oh snap
siren
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right lenny
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh snap
dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
heavens good lord
this is such a strange movie
[Music]
in the best way
[Laughter]
look though the roger rabbit world it's
like a cartoon mixed with an actual good
kung fu movie
might as well
oh nice
[Music]
no i like this guy
you're screwed i want him to die you
really know anything about him
i still like him
he's got some sick moves oh no
what you killed the cat
it's got a more lives it's fine
how do you fight these people oh my god
[Music]
at least you could sense it
oh
how do you fight this guy
[Music]
okay all right just super powers now we
got super strength cool
dad team
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
ouch ouch ouch ouch
[Music]
oh my god her screams be counteracted
well now you're screwed what's gonna do
without the strings
no way
[Music]
the drunken master
sleep happy master oh man
okay we just got whole dudes now
i black canary man
[Music]
oh
yes
[Laughter]
i'm rooting for the axe gang now they're
the underdogs
oh don't do that don't do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uncle donut for donut
[Laughter]
[Music]
actually held on to it after all these
years
oh what the [ __ ] dude no it's the last
time i'll be a hero
[Music]
oh they're going to break that guy out
of
those frogs
[Laughter]
solo
[Laughter]
boy
[Music]
oh my god
oh wow they're right there
oh shoot
that hair though
[Music]
[Applause]
goddamn okay let's let's stop kicking
let's try to use that scream again maybe
just switch it up guys
there it is okay
now we're using our olds
oh he ain't infected at all but oh
oh
god
dammit
wow
[Laughter]
oh this is weakness is he venom is he
allergic to sound
[Music]
[Laughter]
i was like what is she doing
oh my god finally some damage
[Music]
i'm gonna trap him oh you're screwed
no don't listen to him kill him
[Music]
you admitted defeat dishonorable
oh what a funky position to be
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
oh damn
oh
phase two of the boss fight
that's a big fist
oh
what was your plan here dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
he's the chosen one he's the butterfly
in the beginning
[Laughter]
you put that together before the movie
put it together
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's see what you can do
you know he's the protagonist of his
goatee shaved off
[Music]
he's the one
he's just
[Laughter]
big boy stuff
get up there
damn
oh
damn
he broke you out to kill you man
[Music]
he's getting foggy on him
he really is a beast
makes sense where frogs are on the way
to his cell now yeah
good catch
this even its final form
oh
gotcha on that one
with the birdies
[Music]
yes
the power of the buddha you've ascended
my man
said then they explained it right before
it happened
[Music]
[Music]
oh cool wow
no he's a faker don't do it don't listen
to him
oh
yeah
oh my god
oh my god oh geez
[Music]
your ear should be
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's neat
everyone come out of your homes now come
on man dead everyone's here alive
oh
hmm
pop her in the face
[Music]
just clean it up just a little bit
kung fu hustle too so what
where's the second one
that was fun it was a lot of fun wow
wild whacky adventure all right so here
and i are both pretty hungry right now
starting to keep this short but i feel
like it'll be easy to keep short um yeah
you know honestly
i don't even know if i actually saw this
because i was like none of this is
familiar to me
so sometimes you know it's like i
haven't seen i remember like not long
ago i was with a friend and he was
showing me some kurt russell movie
and then when i was watching i'm like
wait a minute i was like 45 minutes into
this going i think i saw this once when
i was a kid and i didn't actually have
that experience at all here of i think i
saw this when i was a kid this this felt
completely brand new to me and even if i
did see when i was younger i don't think
i would have appreciated as much because
all like the types of style and tone and
references to
classic hollywood sometimes very overt
like with the fred astaire uh you know
poster in the background the looney
tunes inspiration was very much there
and i i loved like how it managed to
infuse it with so much creativity
and in a way that felt earnest it felt
sincere like it didn't feel forced at
all in how it wanted to honor all these
different types of styles
in a way that felt natural because a lot
of times you could feel like i get what
you're going for but this is kind of
annoying
it just didn't annoy me it was always
charming and at times the the fight
scenes were just very impressive and
dazzling
so it managed to work on on multiple
levels at times feeling like an anime
too i was very much impressed with this
i thought it was a really really fun
time hey ron hi i thought it was really
fun too i think that it is the perfect
blend of
goofy cartoonery and uh badass action uh
the pacing went by really fast for me
like it was i was hungry the entire time
like i came here straight from work and
it just went by like that it was such a
breeze uh the movie was
uh unexpectedly funny i had no idea how
goofy this movie was i
as we were watching it i had like vague
childhood memories of like certain
flashes of like of of um the old like
the old woman with like the cigarette
and stuff and like her screaming but i
had no context for anything that was
happening and seeing its entirety was
really an experience that i enjoyed a
lot because they're like oh snap this
movie's like wacky and crazy but oh dang
they're like the wire work was insane in
this movie yeah i don't really watch a
lot of chinese movies and old school uh
jackie chan stuff so it was really
refreshing it was coming at it for like
it was it's uh it was fresher for me
yeah i didn't i didn't grow up with a
lot of it so i'm like wow such such
artistry in the the fighting it's so
amazing i mean it had more of the
classic types of
uh peking woo operas what the
stuff from like you and wu ping who did
like the matrix films and um the kill
bill the volume one and uh some other
major crowd she's talking to the dragon
the biggest one so yeah like did those
movies and it had some more of that
inspiration but i like how it managed to
still stay within sort of feeling like a
cartoon because there were times where
the effects were obviously just very
cheap but charming effects and then at
times the effects were actually pretty
cool and how they actually visually
realized a lot of this stuff you know
i i do think that the chosen one
element of the story i was really into
the axe gang i was really into all the
the hidden kung fu warriors living out
in that like poor village like the the
landlord or husband
that part was really interesting to me i
really loved that story line and i did
really like um stephen chow the main guy
i thought like his performance was
really entertaining and i really was
endeared to him at the same time there
was a part of when the chosen one
element came in
that
didn't quite hit me in the way that i
was sort of hoping it would hit me like
it was cool
and maybe it's the fact that we're both
also really hungry so we should have
eaten before then
maybe so but there was there was
something about it that felt like okay
yeah it's it's just happening right now
and it wasn't like yes or or exciting or
the
i don't know maybe something about the
the build to that was it was obvious it
was going to happen but the build to it
didn't feel as maybe cathartic or
rewarding as one would have hoped but
needless to say it was really
entertaining it was always
i think the main goal of this movie is
to entertain you and just have fun and i
think that it excels on that on all
levels like it never felt like
okay
the joke's done or okay the i i'm used
to this now like it managed to still
have surprises throughout and still keep
that inventiveness exciting and i think
at the end of the day if you could pull
that off for 90 straight minutes were
because it was like that thing in the
first 20 minutes i'm like okay this is
really fun but we'll just get will this
get boring and it didn't it managed to
remain amusing and entertaining and and
thrilling throughout with some very
impressive stuff like even the way they
started eventually infusing
like when they did the reveal of the of
the late the landlord lady her husband
i didn't see that coming with her
husband at all like i was like there
must be something with the landlord lady
but with her husband i was like or maybe
he's just some normal dude so that
surprises [ __ ] i mean and finding out a
little bit more of that legendary
quality to them like you're that classic
you're the whatever couple they said
they are you're that couple and then
also with bringing out the villain there
i thought he was menacing so there was a
lot that i really did enjoy about it i i
thought that this was
nothing really i would change i thought
it was like pretty great yeah
yeah i really enjoyed the underdog
quality of all the characters like when
you first meet the people of the village
like you really don't think much of them
or especially the scene where they
introduce that element where uh who the
guy who eventually becomes the
protagonist is like yeah i'll take any
one from the audience
you see the tall dude and the old woman
and then the little buff ass skater like
what the hell so yeah just all the all
the uh protagonists we saw in the the
movie were unexpected heroes and i
really enjoyed that aspect of it and uh
yeah i think a lot of stuff like he was
saying was like
i really enjoyed the the couple and and
yeah i understand what you you were
saying about the uh the payoff not
feeling very triumphant and that could
be in part for us being hungry but i
think part of like i
to be honest i saw the the twist of him
being the chosen one for like maybe like
the first 20 minutes of the movie so i
was like okay like i was watching it
enjoying the journey and enjoying his
character arc but i was like okay when's
he actually gonna throw down and like be
the man he's gonna be for the finale
like at
the the moment i knew that he was the
protagonist when uh when they saw the
two dudes like playing the guitar i'm
like oh it's the it's the scoundrel guy
he's gonna be the the hero of the story
okay cool yeah so
i i enjoy the story and i enjoy the the
action and i definitely see how
um it took both
chinese influences and american
influences and smashed them together in
this weird kind of
um
unexpected hybrid that kind of gels
perfectly together it's like it's not
parody i thought it walked a really
great line between the goofiness of the
movie and the serious aspects of the the
drama and the
the pathos of the movie and yeah i think
i feel like it's a very difficult task
to achieve but this movie managed to to
do it perfectly there was never a point
where
the
the goofiness kind of took me out of the
general story of what was happening yeah
but it was it was meant to be fun like
even though you're supposed to have
pathos i didn't feel a lot in this movie
but i don't think it was trying to make
me
go to the depths of my soul to feel
something so
yeah i guess to close it i have a i had
a great time watching well they did a
lot of very inventive it wasn't just
only goofy too i think like the guys
with the piano uh the music the
instrumental ones
i thought that was really sinister and
inventive in the way they did that like
i've never seen anything like that in
live action ever no most of this i've
never seen in live action ever so the
fact that they managed to do like
things that felt like an anime come to
life in a lot of ways i thought was so
damn impressive and it just you have to
find the right tone for something like
this and i think that's what's so
impressive is like they managed to find
that like dick tracy roger rabbit type
of vibe but then also infuse it with
this chinese influence and i i think the
thing with the chosen one is of why
this because of why did it hit as much
as because the things that landed some
more emotional impact were always the
things that were more outside with with
like the people from the village
and and dealing with the axe gang
directly like the the losses really came
from there and then he would just like
check in
with the scoundrel
you just check back in with him and you
know even though he got his backstory uh
a little bit of like oh he's actually a
good guy at heart i think maybe it could
have just been structured a tad bit
different so that way the the impact
could hit a little bit better or having
to be more involved
you know
as opposed to just really being on his
own and fighting for the axe gang and
stuff like that yeah there are points
where i forgot he was in the movie i was
like oh yeah yeah
like i was never like disinterested in
him i always liked him at the same time
i would be like more interested in with
the other stuff that was going on yeah
versus what was going on with him but it
was still really exciting it was cool
like the whole thing with the palm at
the end i thought that was all [ __ ]
awesome the final fight was great but
yeah this was i could see why this this
movie still holds up and why people love
it so much because
they they uh
to this from 2005 and i still haven't
seen anything like it
yeah almost 20 years later yeah nothing
before nothing since i would love to see
a sequel they kind of set up for that i
don't know if that exists or if that's a
thing but i want to watch it now yeah
because it was a lot of fun
but aaron thanks for being here man
thanks for having me we'll return for
umbrella academy
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thanks for being
here subscribe click that bell aaron and
i are going to rush to go stuff our
faces right now because we are starving
check us out patreon